what's up guys it is thick mother day
it's saturday morning and we're about to
start the tough mudder in glen helen
raceway i got my boys with me
bart's missing a shirt what up couldn't
find it get your titties out of my face
big map
let's go
[Applause]
no i just appreciate you guys i see all
the big butter shirts and everything we
have so much fun
you know it's not about how fast you
finish together you help each other out
we'll leave anybody behind it'll be a
great time good get fat and get really
thick and uh
hot dogs and
stuff today
[Music]
i'll see you guys
[Applause]
[Music]
about two and a half miles in i'm all
right
all right
think about your own i think madden's
a little far back
let's see how mark's feeling yo yo yo
that was that was first that was the
toughest obstacle so far trying to
slaughter my ass down that whole
uh hillside right there
i'm going to be sunburned but it's going
to be worth it because i'll have a story
to go along with it and i'm just glad
it's not cold i'm glad it's not so
freezing that i can't feel my hands
mark's lips
no it's true
the hot water's nice though that's a
nice touch
too many doghouse
[Music]
i finally want to get through one of
these things without falling i'll make
it through to the end sometimes and then
fall right when you grab onto the final
pull so every single time i fall in the
water this time i'm going to try my best
to actually make it all the way to the
other side
[Music]
i am not a statistic i'm not a victim i
failed i bounced back i did the damn
thing i mattered all the way through but
i kind of want to go in the water
actually
[Music]
not as [ __ ] out here but i'm really glad
that we're not in the cold like the lake
elsewhere was
i couldn't feel
my hands for the entire time
so it's hot
it's uncomfortable my throat's dry but
i'm actually really thankful for that
how am i feeling like a goddamn champion
brendan's still up there i haven't seen
him anywhere all right let's get him on
a funky monkey i'll meet you guys there
okay okay that's the golf what's the
goal go get money no the goal is to show
him what a ninja warrior does at a tough
mudder course calling out brendan
calling you out
with love and affection that's not
that's not aggression
[Music]
electric heels not good shot twice
no joke it is not a light shock i'm
trying to kill you over there
[Music]
at first i was like why is everybody
going so slow
now i [ __ ] know
[Music]
that's what happens when your ass is
[Music]
that's it
[Music]
austin texas one night only saturday
your boy he's stepping it up i'm not at
caps anymore i'm at the paramount
theater hall at your boy one show one
night only i'm at moon tower comedy
festival come get some i'm actually on
my way there now running so that's why
i'm always